Heroin, Crack Cocaine, Crystal Meth, Krispy
Kreme – these are some of the most addictive
and most dangerous recreational drugs in the
world.
But there’s an even more dangerous drug,
a substance so terrifying that it would have
brought David Bowie back down to Earth.
Meet Burundanga, also known as Scopolamine
and by its street name “Devil’s Breath”.
Take this and you’ll wake up in a strange
location with your bank account empty and
all your worldly possessions missing.
As has happened to many a victim of this incredibly
powerful drug.
Burundanga is not a drug taken recreationally,
in fact it’s a drug that even the most hardcore
of substance abusers would steer well clear
of.
Burundanga is found in the leaves, roots and
seeds of the Borrachero tree.
The most common way to process the drug, ready
for sale on the street, is by taking the seeds
from the pod and and grinding them and bleaching
them into a white powder.
I know, another white powder, how very original.
The tree grows in abundance in Columbia, and
not just in the wilderness, the tree can be
seen lining the streets of huge cities like
Bogota, even growing in people’s gardens.
Although relatively unknown to the rest of
the world, the residents of Columbia know
all too well about the plant and its dangers.
Columbians make sure they never fall asleep
beneath a Borrachero tree, because it’s
so toxic that even inhaling its scent for
too long is enough to send an individual into
an agonising trip for days and even cause
instant death.
There are thousands of urban myths about the
Burundanga drug, and the horrific stories
that have become those who’ve unwittingly
taken the drug.
One story documented in a scientific paper
tells of a young man who amputated his own
tongue and penis after drinking just one cup
of tea made using Burundanga.
The drug basically supresses your free-will
and makes you susceptible to doing absolutely
anything you are told to.
It’s so effective in fact that it was used
as a truth serum by the CIA; they got a whole
lot of truth, but they also got a load of
stories about purple elephants and complete
rubbish as well, because of its powerful hallucinogenic
properties.
In Columbia the drug is used for only two
purposes, to rob or to kill.
Often by organised gangs.
It is common for a gang member to blow the
powder into the face or wipe it across the
nose and mouth of an unsuspecting member of
the public.
Within seconds the person is under the drug’s
powerful spell and there’s not a thing they
can do to stop it.
Once drugged, the victim looses all self-will
and will happily do whatever the attacker
asks, even if it causes physical or financial
harm to themselves or others.
The victim is then told to hand over their
wallet and even to drive to their home and
help the thieves to empty their own house
of all their most expensive possessions and
hand them over to the thieves.
The worst part about all this is that the
victim isn’t even aware that they’re high,
so to them it feels completely normal to want
to give away all their money and possessions.
And what makes this the perfect criminal drug
is that the victim won’t remember a single
thing about the incident, not who gave it
to them or what the person made them do.
As you might expect it’s also used as a
date-rape drug.
However, it’s more commonly used by prostitutes
to rob unsuspecting Johns in clubs.
Pimps often supply their prostitutes with
Burundanga and the girls seduce susceptible
looking men in bars, then when they’re not
looking the women spike the victim’s drink
with the drug.
Within a few minutes of the victim ingesting
the deadly liquour, they will either be dead
because the dosage was slightly too high,
which happens all too often in Columbia, or
completely at the mercy of the prostitute’s
every command.
It’s then common for the women to drive
their victims around town asking the victim
to withdraw all their monies from a series
of ATMs and hand it over, which they gladly
oblige to, because they have lost their ability
to say “no”.
And that’s what truly makes this the scariest
drug in the world.
Women have also known to have been drugged
with Burundanga and kidnapped, then used as
prostitutes to earn money for the kidnappers.
By keeping the women continuously drugged
for days they won’t put up any resistance
and are in fact extremely willing to do horrendous
things.
Burundanga or Scolopamine, as it’s known
clinically, is on the World Health Organization’s
List of Essential Medicines – a list of
the most important medications needed in a
basic health system, as it’s used in the
medical field in moderate doses to treat motion
sickness and supress nausea.
It’s therefore crazy to think that in a
slightly higher dosage this substance can
be used for evil.
But then again, what more would you expect
from Columbia, the drug capital of the western
world.
The bottom line is whether it be Weed, Cocaine
or Scolopamine, don’t do drugs, it’s just
bloody stupid.
Thanks for watching.